[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
one of my favorites is the joke about
how you started smoking cigarettes so
young yeah I was 12.
you also you also played with action
figures until you were 13. she figures
until I was like 15. and there was like
a years of
overlaps and playing action figures
I like wrote that joke but the um the
actual origin like the the day yeah that
I always remember was it was summer
vacation probably between seventh and
eighth grade yeah so I was at home yeah
you know I could stay alone I was like
12. and so I was home alone my mom would
go to work she was gone all day I
remember in the morning USA would play
Wings hell yeah
yeah yeah and I sat on the floor with my
WWF Hasbro figures in the ring
battling yeah I'm just like just
battling and then I finish your match
you know probably have a new champ yeah
and then I'd go on the side of my house
and I had a soft pack of Marlboro Reds
smoking it yeah thinking about like [ __ ]
maybe maybe Triple H you can go get the
straps I probably think of Tatanka for
the IC
maybe we do like a Hogan Undertaker
steel cage
I'm booking it I'm fantasy booking it on
the side of my house and then I remember
I went in the house and I got uh dizzy
from smoking you know yeah of course the
first yeah yeah so I was like oh and I
laid down yeah and I just remember
laying down sideways on the couch
watching Doogie Howser and then like
rolling off and going right back to
playing
with that noise or go oh yeah yeah oh
and then the Ovation
my lighter's slipping out of my [ __ ]
sweat shorts
you dealt drugs you did drugs and you
got robbed by a drug dealer yeah I
didn't there you played all the parts in
that movie I didn't really ever deal
drugs I lived with a drug I lived with a
guy that sold weed right it's like weird
to call him a drug dealer's the house I
was like the guy on the couch you really
played the video games with the drug
dealers in between I was the lobby right
vlalimir while Amir can I get you a
coffee or drink yeah well he would I
would load the bubbler we'd play like
some you know Home Run Derby on
PlayStation two yeah and I was funny
yeah so I was like the secretary yeah Mr
Miz weighing out your quarter pound
honey take a seat
is this your first time buying from them
you know it comes from Victoria British
Columbia
the sound the Sandusky thing the most
[ __ ] up part is that in one of the
descriptions they said that someone just
heard the sound like they're like the
cheeks clapping yeah oh no wait yeah
there's like one report where they're
like I just walked on her and the
chief's clapping and how does that
that's gonna [ __ ] you up dude you can't
[ __ ] after that that's the opposite of
hearing Chappelle's voice around the
corner you're like you're like no no
someone better have been hanging up a
picture yeah that's the worst part about
that is like as soon as you verbalize
that publicly everybody knows that
that's what you're thinking about when
you're staring off in the space anytime
like you're in the den your wife's like
honey if you wanted a piece of lemon
cake and she sees the look of your eyes
I would be hearing it up until the
gunshots yeah I couldn't go to an event
where applause was a thing
it just sounds like millions of kids are
being moved to right there stop clapping
for them oh no the finger Snaps are even
worse we'll stop please
I think that's those are little penises
being slapped against tongues I can't do
that no oh do you think today's camera
did that you ever think you ever did
smack on his own face
do you ever think he was nasty with them
coach or whatever I don't know oh my God
the kid goes like no there was one time
he got nasty with me that was the worst
part dude I walked around my block for
like 10 days I'm like someone's gonna
throw out a [ __ ] shitty chair
someone's gonna throw a [ __ ] that's like
but that's like the folding chair I
think if you're like if you run across
that not looking for it it's good luck
but going to try to find something like
that I would imagine it'd be hard
because all the chairs that the universe
will throw at you will be like an office
chair yeah or like a child's gym you
don't want any of that [ __ ] and I did
find I I started laughing because one
time I found like a small baby folding
chair I'm like that would be funny
just like when he's like I [ __ ] laid
out a toddler I just I [ __ ] know an
extreme rules match with a kindergarten
it was a [ __ ] Texas death metal [ __ ]
and this [ __ ] baby was going down
loser takes a nap
but they're like I will not dude Logan
is like loser leaves preschool yeah
tonight loser finds out Santa isn't real
tonight at the ECW Arena I'm gonna tell
you right now
you're a mean person I know the naughty
list you [ __ ] [ __ ] like whoa I
love the cooties on you dude cooties is
two the bet if you were a child wrestler
and your finishing move wasn't called
cooties dude hits him with the cooties
child wrestling the Indian rug burning
just like oh my God
got him again
tapping dude they throw easy the army
that comes down he's got him in a noogie
he's giving him
I've never seen a Nookie like that
before children wrestling moves dude
just having two kids yeah beat the [ __ ]
out of one another that would be fun if
you have children and you're watching
this and they wrestle definitely start
throwing in some Jr on it dude I uh I I
was a I wrestled all through my like
childhood and into Middle School oh man
so there's a lot of pictures of you
doing this
that's where my dad went from being like
a couch alcoholic that worked at a
liquor store but still could get it
together enough to get 49ers tickets
from his garbage
from the garbage man I swear to God
Teddy the garbage man God gave us Niners
tickets and we went it was like Steve
Young's first start against the Rams
really yeah it was like back when
Montana got traded to the Chiefs it was
unbelievable
and yeah dude Teddy the garbage man gave
us like it's only Shady when you have a
personal relationship with the garbage
man what are you doing in the nine
seconds that he's out front of your
house
yo that's exactly it shut it up they're
bombing stigs and lighters with each
other my dad will go outside and rip a
Marlboro Red and talk to Teddy my dad
was like I'm very much my father's
personality which is just like hey you
want to talk I'll talk to you for
[ __ ] three hours yeah and uh and then
I find out that the mob like really runs
the garbage in San Francisco like really
Way Beyond New York obviously waste
management but like San Francisco the
mom had a Stranglehold on the the
[ __ ] collection yeah collection and
then I realized Teddy was like a good
looking Italian kid
this kid was probably [ __ ] mobbed up
and that's why we got like
20th row 40 yard line tickets to the
Niners that were the owners I'm like
dude you're the [ __ ] opening manager
of a liquor store Mill Valley
so we used to like that's great no child
support but Steve Young comes up to you
after yeah
good to see you get the high five Huey
Lewis in his prime uh I bet he's only
throwing out guys in rolled up carpets
Teddy gives my dad manila envelope and
he goes like hey why don't you get this
[ __ ] off your back
buy to get a guitar
why don't you kick a little to that
noisy [ __ ] in Colorado he's into what
the Ninja Turtles what are they called
goes by the way we can stop by and make
life for his stepfather very painful I
got some people in Aurora it's okay he
goes listen I got a cousin he's out in
Aurora because he's got a hot sheet
right now he's laying low but he can
still do all I'm saying is it'd be a
shame if your son's stepfather had a
broken hip did he have like a step-dad
name like Joe Joe yeah Joe's a good one
I mean I talk about it on stage but he
was my Dad's ex-best friend
and he was like they'd come in wait a
second hold up don't you can't he's my
godfather he was your godfather so who's
your godfather who's your Dad's ex-best
friend yeah yeah and and just he slid in
there yeah so they how long after oh
like eight years
I mean not not listen it's never cool
it's never cool it's never cool was he
just like at first he was over talking
with your mom about your dad and then
you yeah we moved him from Connecticut
to Colorado because for some reason my
mom and I were like sitting around was
the summer of the 96 Olympic Games and I
was like oh you should Joe and his wife
were my parents friends obviously
because my godfather right I was like
when's the last time you talked to Joe
and Lynn and my mom's like Oh [ __ ] since
like 89 and I was like call him up and I
did it to myself I was like you should
see how Joe's doing so my mom called Joe
he was divorced my mom was single they
were talking and then my mom we were
looking for a roommate so my mom's like
how did you feel about Joe but you guys
were looking for a roommate yeah yeah
there was like this one time in my mom's
you know you know where she we were like
we need the help right where it'll help
out we'll have a roommate I love the
fact that you were just like an
eight-year-old kid I was uh I was like
12. brainstorming Revenue options
streaming Revenue I want to put her on
only fans now you're like wait mom have
you thought about this Mom I'm gonna
toss this out there what if I get some
Spyderco Knives we go door to door I
sell it if you hear three people me and
my mom just pushing magazine
subscriptions Marie Claire has got a
brand new deal for you 14 issues
um yeah you ended up you were trying to
figure out how to rent one of the rooms
out I liked Joe because I only knew him
as like my Dad's friend no
eight-year-old should have to think this
stuff through again I was 12. you were
12. sorry about that you're an adult I
apologize honestly with eight it would
be more acceptable because it's pie-eyed
and it's like Dad's friend 12 you're
like all right kid [ __ ] what are you
doing you put yourself In Harm's Way
yeah I don't know how they I don't know
how they consider uh when they consider
adulthood in the midwest but 12 I think
is pretty young Colorado Laws 100 years
ago I would have had to have had my own
Farm by then yeah you probably would
have yeah you would have had to leave I
would have had a dorm on an Indian tribe
they go if you can't drive cattle why
are you here
damn it Dad so Joe you meet you so you
you hook your mom and Joe up
unintentionally completely unintentional
yeah and it ends up being the one did
you at least pay a little rent for a
little bit in that room yeah they faked
it yeah and then there became a time
where it was like a rainstorm and I went
to piss and I remember it's like really
storming outside and the lightning
struck and I saw that his door was like
a haunted like a scary movie and I
noticed this door was open and I was
like I'll shut Joe's door and I like
looked in and his he wasn't in his bed
and I was like damn I immediately knew I
was like damn did he play it off for a
while like you I gave it a couple days
and then finally with my mom I was like
so Joe's sleeping in your room and she
was like oh we were gonna tell you and
you're like all right all right and it
was just like you know he had never had
kids he didn't he played over a while
like he came out of a room Nick and you
were like he was like oh sorry I was I
was in the air conditioner it was crazy
your mother was trapped under a boulder
and I had to get her out and you're like
okay cool yeah no no I knew I was like
all right and then everything was start
I again it was still so stupid I didn't
put it together that it was going to
turn terrible right but yeah then it's
like
you have no control of the situation
then all of a sudden my ranking got
dropped when he was a roommate
we were evil we were even ranking you
could go to his room and be like hey
yeah Hey Joe you're using a little too
much hot water buddy
I come in with a tool belt right I mean
he didn't fix that thing that you said
downstairs it's like oh it's a little
bit of some of the ceilings falling off
I'm having super conversations
lady owns this building he's a real
[ __ ]
just busting my ass about my grades
there's a Dwayne Reed by my new
apartment but it's also a Walgreens yeah
they own each other yeah didn't know
that
I'm at the Dwayne Reed and I'm like
looking for something
see a black dude doing some stuff with a
tag on and I go hey and it's Walgreens
they go
I tried to get out of it mid-ass and
then I was like
shooter
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] dude I thought I [ __ ]
up because I walked up I was like yes no
oh [ __ ] yeah I mean I'll ask as soon as
I walk into a hardware store I ask a
stranger I mean because they know the
hardware guys don't they don't have
uniforms so if you're a man yeah they're
back you know what you're doing here
yeah oh do they if you're wearing a back
brace at Home Depot I'm gonna ask her
stuff somebody sent me something that
was very interesting
I can't say who it is because they told
me not to say who it is
but they sent me something on Facebook
and I've always suspected this
and this is so [ __ ] blatant my name
my real name is Ricardo Aguilera I'll
tell you the whole thing I killed Dan
Soder in 2007 and took over his identity
I'm Argentinian no they come from a
powerful family that is hell-bent on
violence and destruction I did that was
not that I made myself into a silly man
hoping to
get washed away into the comedy scene
but here we are
I'll tell you this Robert Kelly
you have just sent several dangerous
people after you
anyways let's listen to the files
Louis J Gomez is My Bodyguard
he is my trusted assistant Raphael
we're both from Buenos Aires
Robert do what you will but the
Argentinian people know I am there for
them
uh I believe Buenos Aires I am that's in
Argentina oh is it [ __ ] [ __ ]
yes my grandfather has escaped Nazi but
that is not one of my family's story
it's where it starts
is it a j-o video
is it the business side okay yeah I want
to talk to that guy yeah dude that guy's
very he's still okay I've seen some
things my friend
I always would love to do it yeah where
where where did you grow up as a boy on
the shores on the shores of the ocean
watching the powerful sea push out
things that he did no longer want
including my father a simple shrimp
Center sailor what
ah dude I'm a [ __ ] idiot you can only
pretend to be smart for so long where
did you did you go to school ah the
streets taught me my friend everything I
needed to know
I would learn from Ali cats from
gangsters
from City from city councilman
until I was the most powerful man in
Buenos Aires
did you see I'm sorry did you say you
learned from Alley Cats Alley Cats and
street from Street vendors the drug
pushers
and of course the horse teaching me to
be an excellent lover
I went how old are you now I am 48 years
old 48 but I look a much younger man yes
because of the love of my wife oh you're
married Rosalita Rose she passed away
several years ago oh she's dead [ __ ]
cancer
she died very brutally
[ __ ] out the love of me in a bloody
little liquid mess who is your father
he's I killed him myself is that I said
you said the sea took him away my middle
name is C
water parks to me the I remember my dad
took me to one
called Waterworks near San Francisco it
was like in the Bay Area and they would
give you this like sponge that you would
go down on yeah
it's it was a sponge shanathan and the
thing the thing [ __ ] dropped and I
just remember them being like it's
really scary I'm like no I was maybe
like eight and it dropped and I was like
I made a noise in front of other kids
that I was embarrassed the rest of the
day I was like that was my I was
actually afraid
come on
anytime someone asked me like what would
you do with like a million dollars like
I one of my things which I've already
told on that golf thing about like a a
fun
system of of uh like uh when you go to a
driving range yeah you'd have one slot
for a certain Sport and in the distance
certain rings to hit like sir golf you
have a point system are you inventing
Topgolf
are you in front of us to tell you this
driving range there's chicken fingers
and wings and nachos and get beer and
it's stacked on them
he's not even saying that he wants to
invent it he just wants to go dude
I've been making [ __ ] your brains right
now Tommy we can go to Topgolf on
Thursday I can take you there on
Thursday 39.99
nice I wasn't done all right all right
no but it's more it's all sports so it's
like you go to another session you bring
the distance in it's football okay I
mean then you go so maybe you get for
the lesbians some softball under you
bring it in a little bit good luck
softball pitches he just wants a bar
with chicks
they can watch him throwing it he just
wants girls going wow you're so natural
yeah athletic because basically right
here it's like a [ __ ] buffet and they
just watch me go down and I [ __ ]
ing
home
I hit a three and they suck me off
anyway the second idea I wanted was a
[ __ ] adult uh you already sent a
waiver yeah like the action park was in
Jersey yeah but bars at the bottom of
everyone like like you flow right into a
lagoon oh that's fun a pool bar but
there you pick up speed and [ __ ] shit's
a little dangerous you gotta wear
helmets
real fun time the best part will be in
uh if this process even moved forward
would be the inevitable shutdown by the
insurance company or they're like we're
not going to try it yeah we can't
possibly [ __ ] talking yeah talking
about putting in a bar at the end of a
pool at an event of a slide that's very
dangerous yeah tell me he's like I'll
cover I got a million bucks
sure that's not even gonna get you the
we're not even talking about the land
leasing you can't even violate
and you go there's a cooler at the end
that's the bar you guys can see the
concept didn't really take off you know
it's just wet in the ground with a hose
yeah sliding down the hill
you guys Tommy's field yet
you got a voice on you there was there's
been times where I've called a
restaurant right like with a problem I
ordered food and there's like a problem
I call him like hey what's going on with
this like disorders [ __ ] terrible and
it didn't come out right the guy's like
hey Andre the Giants
oh I love my song troops are all your
song chips
it didn't show up and I'm like hey and
they're just like I've seen guys be like
this
I find it now more interesting to be
like oh what is the history of Colorado
yeah because I know it is a white kid
that grew up in the suburbs right that
went to [ __ ] the Aurora mall right or
went to [ __ ] you know like the Best
Buy on Mississippi right you're like oh
It's the Best Buy and you're like did
you know that that actually plot a land
belonged to the legal you know like so
they were like whoa [ __ ] that's pretty
[ __ ] up win hundreds of years ago and
they're like no a hundred years ago
yeah your grandmother was like don't get
me started yeah because I dated one
you're like what he was great it would
flip me around on his horse yeah I dated
never calls you back that was his name
Mary sorry Mary Lou I just felt like we
didn't really hit it off the son told
the coyote to not call you
I went to the river for a message but
realized that the snake had taken my
love for you it's like what does that
mean runs with storms are having sex
with your sister it means I'm kind of
over it yeah
it's got to be like uh
something by just playing
blame soul of the of the world and you
can blame anything damn why did you show
up and you go oh I just felt like the
wind the uh yeah the soul of the wind
told me to go home and take a nap
anytime I'm about to break up with a
girl I'll just start doing meditation
and yoga just so I can be like one with
my spirits to like blame it on that yeah
like I'm just really doing a lot of you
know inner works not you it's my chakras
say that it's not right and do you
respect that and she's like yeah now if
you had any Native American blood you
can tell them that an eagle came and saw
you yeah and brought the spirit of the
wind
yeah I am destined for other [ __ ]
foreign
[Music]